ses dernières cartes postales de
vacances en part sur le bassin
d'arcachon à flot le bateau traditionnel
la pinasse très à la mode chez l'épicier
david béziers sébastien en 4 au premier
regard quand on n'est pas d'arcachon une
pinasse ça ressemble à une barre mais ce
bateau de travail des ostréiculteurs
d'autrefois rencontre un fabuleux destin
elle a bien failli mourir mais depuis
quatre ans les notables se précipitent
pour participer à la régate des nerfs et
my hair es mon avis qu'ils viennent dans
les ors un petit peu et ça nous fait
plaisir de communiquer un petit concept
de tradition mais il est vrai que les
puristes passionnés de pinasses ont du
mal à faire partager ses qualités
sportives
par vent faible une pinasse ça n'avance
pas
autre pinasse même trou même élégance
faible tirant d'eau
celle là est sorti de sa coquille
d'huître pour transporter l'autre
richesses du bassin d'arcachon les
touristes dans les années 25 30
il ya une évolution donc de la pinasse
elle a eu des petites modifications on
lui a mis
une timonerie
l'ue a mis les petits abris des petits
accessoires en bois taux bien sûr avec
venu tout de suite bien plus élégante
conçu pour promener les bourgeois de la
belle époque on l'appelait pinasse de
monsieur l'activité renaît dans le même
esprit pour 300 à 450 euros la
demi-journée plaisance à la carte
le prix d'un débarquement insolite sur
la dune du pilat nous suggère des
endroits à découvrir jeu très agréable
on trouve dans une ambiance un peu
lunaire loin de loin des plages un peu
traditionnelle donc ses sympathies
aujourd'hui monsieur achète fait rénover
les pinasses aux revues par les
meilleurs charpentier de marine comme
une maîtresse il les couvre de bijoux
acajou cave à vin 220000 on s'achète un
run histoire d'amour de patrimoine s'il
ya la demande du basso la pinasse
modifier ou vraiment du sur mesure
et là on peut atteindre des bateaux très
très originaux comme celui de fini tard
quand le designer rencontre la barque du
début de ce reportage
voilà le résultat désormais madame qui
n'a c'est très tendance